expecto patronum
there is nothing like escaping to
hogwarts and indulging in all that the
wizarding world has to offer
but how would the harry potter films
look if we stripped away the magic
would voldemort still be as threatening
would wand duels look as epic it's time
to find out
wow look at it the new nimbus 2000
quidditch it's a huge part of harry
hogwarts and literally the entire world
of magic
it's actually one of the first parts of
the wizarding world we get to see come
to life
but without a green screen quidditch and
broom flying isn't all it's cut out to
be
to bring the magic to life the actors
would sit on an actual broom that was
attached to a rig
the rig was pre-programmed with the
movements to make it look like the
actors were fighting a dragon or
catching a golden snitch
quidditch is great best game there is
and you'll be great too
the final showdown between voldemort and
harry had to be epic
it's what the entire series was leading
up to after all
however a lot of movie magic was needed
to bring out the real magic
the hogwarts grounds in the background
the magic shooting out of their wands
voldemort disintegrating into
nothingness we can watch that scene over
and over
but let's check out what that scene
looks like without cgi and a green
screen
basically two actors pointing wooden
sticks at each other
not that daniel radcliffe and ralph
finds aren't amazing actors though
also how weird is it to see voldemort
with a nose you've been taught how to do
well i presume yes
first we bow to each other speaking of
the dark lord in his nose
voldemort's soulless appearance was also
thanks to the help of something magical
it's called vfx they use these effects
to not only edit ralph's entire face
including his snake-like nose but to
also get the voldemort we see at the
beginning of the deathly hallows
remember him soaring above the sky
trying to figure out which of the seven
harrys was the real one
harry potter is dead
who else thinks that the goblet of fire
is the most magical movie of them all
from the quidditch world cup to the yule
ball there was nothing quite like the
magical vibes that came with the golden
trio's fourth year at hogwarts
including the tri-wizard tournament
hogwarts
has been chosen to host a legendary
event
in harry's first task he has to maneuver
around a dragon
and snatch up the golden egg but without
the help of cgi
the scene is almost magicless the
dragons are actually computer-generated
based on a scan of a model dragon
and we already know how they brought the
broom flying to life who wants me to
open it
[Applause]
perry's second task is even more lethal
than the first and surprisingly more
magical
daniel radcliffe did take a deep dive
for the scene so we really are seeing
him swimming
and the gills he grows thanks to
neville's gillyweed are also visible
thanks to prosthetics
however everything else is completely
missing without the help of computers
the great lake was actually a water tank
with a blue screen and the grindylows
they were all added in later on
daniel was just given instruction on
where he should turn and react so it
could look magical later on
there aren't mer people in the black
lake are there
the third and final task is tragic but
still very supernatural
we see harry's first face-off with
voldemort in his actual form
their magic collides and in an epic
finale harry gets to see his past loved
ones
one more time as their ghosts help him
to escape back to the safety of hogwarts
we can ring it for a moment to give you
some time but only a moment you
understand
however if you take a look at this video
you'll see just how different this scene
would look without its magic
even the maze wasn't actually there who
doesn't wish they could have a dobby of
their own
where would harry be without the house
elf and even though creature is a bit
more standoffish he does help out harry
in the seventh film
but we're sad to say that house elves
unfortunately
aren't real who are you dobby sir
dobby the house elf in fact during the
filming of their scenes
dobby and creature are actually just
actors in grey motion suits
check out how bizarre these scenes look
before the final cut they would also
have models of the elves on set for
reference
a dobby saw creature in diagon alley
which dobby thought was
curious the seventh film started off
with a bang
seven of them to be exact but just how
would the scene with seven harry's look
if we broke it down
well for starters there weren't actually
seven daniel radcliffes
instead dan filmed each of the harry's
parts separately in front of a green
screen
then they were all added in using
effects later on including the morphing
of his face
the crew claims that this was one of the
trickiest scenes to make magical just
because of how closely they had to pay
attention in order for everything to
work out perfectly
we did also have to say break the record
for the most number of takes
ever done if there's one thing harry
potter is known for
it's their moving images you see them
throughout the movies in places like
books
newspapers and in the photos that line
the walls of hogwarts
they even have personalities
this but they're not real sorry to pop
your magical bubble but they're actually
not even regular photos
blue screens were put in as a substitute
for where the pictures would go
and the gift-like videos were added on
by editors after the filming was
complete
harry and buckbeak a match made in
heaven
okay maybe that was taking it a little
too far but harry did help save his life
we finally have some good news for you
buckbeak was technically on set
he existed but he was mechanical they
had to make three different buck beaks
so they could get him performing
different movements properly
then the cgi team would step in and make
him super lifelike
they had to create and edit every single
feather on buckbeak
buckbeak now lives in the harry potter
museum take a look at this fans video
say hello to buckbeat we get quite a few
different scenes with the room of
requirement
and let's face it it's probably one of
the coolest things at hogwarts
there was one scene in the room
specifically that really stands out
it happens in the eighth and final film
while harry is on the search for
ravenclaw's diadem
of course draco and his minions had to
have one last go at harry and in turn
the room ends up full of flames and we
get to see harry on his broom for a
final time
but if we strip this scene down it's a
whole lot of green screen with the
actors strapped into harnesses
on fire if you watched fantastic beasts
you know that nagini has a backstory of
her own she's not just voldemort's pet
and horcrux
which means it was only right they give
her some epic magical scenes in harry
potter
but all the credit for that really goes
to the visual effects team
during filming nagini wasn't there which
probably made the actor's job a little
more difficult when they were meant to
be interacting or looking at her
nevertheless they managed to pull it off
perfectly we might add
and gave us some epic nagini scenes
goblins are one of the first creatures
from the wizarding world that we meet
alongside harry in his first year
but there's one goblin that plays an
extra special role in bringing down
voldemort
even if he does betray harry ron and
hermione it's grip hook
like dobby and creature there was a
prosthetic model made of grip hook but
they also covered warwick davis and
prosthetics in order to bring the
mythical creature to our screens
i don't look right i am too good looking
the three
dangerous tasks weren't the only magical
things that surrounded the tri-wizard
tournament
the tri-wizard cup itself took a lot of
work to become magical
on set of the film the actors were
surrounding a pretty ordinary trophy
there were no blue flames or age line
that prevented the weasley twins from
dropping in their names
and during the choosing ceremony the cup
didn't actually spit out the paper with
harry's name on it in a dramatic fury of
flames
that was all added in after filming
i don't know the whomping willow was
pretty unforgiving to harry and friends
during their time at hogwarts
with its relentless branches it
definitely took them on a ride
and watching how they made the tree come
to life is another ride altogether
of course a lot of it was green screen
but they actually had a fake branch that
actors like emma watson would hop on to
imitate the movements
the behind the scenes of this might not
look magical but it sure does look cool
so potterheads what do you think seeing
these side-by-side comparisons
definitely shocked us
did taking the magic away from these
scenes make them any less epic
what moment were you most shocked to see
stripped down come chat with us in the
comment section below
make sure to hit that subscribe button
to stay up to date with all things the
things
thanks for watching